if you remember back to the last last
caesium video Pete Neil tried to launch
a bit of caesium metal into into water
with the small metallic Collider and
they had a few problems with surface
area and the caesium still being stuck
in the glass as well what I've been
asked to do today is take this ampule of
caesium into this piece of machinery
here which is one of our glove boxes and
try and get it out of the glass so that
we can put it in as is
cesium has quite a surprising use it's
used to measure time I don't know if
you've ever thought about it but you
could define one second as a fraction of
a day one sixtieth of a minute which is
a sixtieth of an hour which is then a
twenty fourth of a day but the trouble
with that is that you'd never be able to
tell whether the earth was going slower
or speeding up because the length of the
day would change and you wouldn't notice
it so scientists have to have an
independent way of defining the second
and this is where cesium comes in and so
now here the cesium is going in as well
all right shut the port door so the way
that physicists define the second is in
terms of microwaves and the frequency of
the microwaves we need a standard
something that can define them radio
wave very very precisely and this is
where cesium comes in so what I need to
do now is open up this door here the
point about cesium is that it's a big
atom it can absorb microwaves the
absorption of the microwave causes an
electron to move from one energy level
to another and the advantage of cesium
over all other materials is that this
frequency is enormous ly precise it's
pretty cool it's really good system kind
of really pale gold color it's still
molten at the moment it's rather like
tuning a radio I don't know if you've
ever tuned a radio but as you turn the
knob sometimes you can don't have to be
very precise you can put it almost
anywhere and you get your favorite
station but there are some stations
where you have to adjust it very very
accurately and there's just one tiny
place where you can get the right radio
station and cesium is like that it
defines the frequency very very
accurately if you don't hit it right
doesn't absorb the radio waves and so
you can use it as a standards to make
sure that everybody has exactly the same
frequency of their microwave and then
once everybody's got the same then it's
quite easy for everybody to agree that
they will count a certain number of
waves as being a second we're gonna
store our store the cesium under oil so
it doesn't react with a when it comes
out so this is ready now for peeps to
check it in some water and we all sound
very far back when he does it so we've
got cesium we've taken it out of the
ampule Neil did that the other day with
Debbie in a glove box they put it into a
small plastic way in both and immerse it
in oil so it can't react with the air
now what we need to do is a very
technical operation which is to punch a
hole in the plastic or both plastic
boats so that we can lift it out with a
piece of string to drop it into some
water I've got my friend dr. red it's
always good to be very very careful when
you do chemistry like this so just in
case something goes wrong we have the
safety procedures ready for us in case
we get surprised
so now Neil is going to pass a piece of
string through the hole so that we can
put it on the end of a rather long
fishing line so that we can drop it into
water
so I'm mrs. Neal's new device it's a
very very fancy erection essentially
we've used a little Bora Tory stand and
we have an eyelet so this is just to act
as a point which we can raise up our
caesium on a piece of string at the
moment the caesium you can see the
lovely gold colour it did you believe me
melting look at it yeah it's very
warming today the sea seems melted so
we're just gonna try and freeze it again
well we're gonna try and refreeze the
caesium by cooling it with liquid
nitrogen okay everybody be careful
so we have our caesium under oil we now
need to lift it up using the new device
and then drop it in the water and let's
see what sort of chemical reaction it
does today everybody ready
nil
well quite a spectacular reaction as the
caesium reacted with the water gave away
its electron off she goes as caesium
plus awesome that's pretty good
yeah it's great you know when when
Debbie and Neal took the caesium at the
ampoule they were really really good for
us because they gave us a really large
surface area so it could react quickly
as soon as it went in the water
generating all that lovely hydrogen
ready to explode and make a bang
great good chemistry well the reason
that caesium reacts so violently is that
it is a very large atom so an electron
can be removed very easily in fact if
you dissolve seeds in in water on a very
short time scale and millionth of a
second or so it dissociates into cesium
plus and an electron and the energy of
the electron interacting with the water
is enough to separate the two and once
the electron is in the water it then
reacts with the water so that h2o
dissociates into a hydrogen atom and Oh
H - so in fact what you're making is a
caesium salt which is rather like
caustic soda it's a strong alkali and
hydrogen and it is the rapid formation
of hydrogen gas that causes part of the
shock of the reaction and then the
hydrogen will usually catch fire and
react with the oxygen in the air to give
you a small explosion or a big one
depending how much caesium you've used
you